are you ready to optimize your health
and defeat the aging process but you
know you need some help need some
guidance the sponsors of this next
segment regenerate medical concierge is
here for you
hi i'm dr amin and this is my office
regenerate medical concierge we are
primarily a anti-aging health and
wellness clinic
we do numerous things here including iv
therapy hormone replacement but
anti-aging specifically is actually a
bit of a misnomer
we can't technically reverse aging just
yet
however another another term for it is
health and wellness optimization and the
goal there is ideally to slow down aging
you know there's a number of ways we can
do that one of them is using wrinkled
relaxers things like botox dysport
xeomin and these really just help
prevent wrinkles from forming by
preventing the skin from moving the
other options include medications there
are certain meds that help our body
eliminate cells that
are
not so healthy or on their way to
becoming not so healthy we do a
medically guided weight loss plans here
specifically geared at helping people
lose their fat concentration in the
bodies
while maintaining their muscle mass
some of the other things we can do is
genetic testing and with the with the
help of genetics we can look at
eliminating certain components
of a person's lifestyle that for them
specifically may not be as beneficial as
they could be for other people
and then one of the other components we
can look at is telomere testing with
technology today we can actually look at
how long a person's telomeres are
and
the longer they are
the longer a person's lifespan can be
and there are medications and uh various
treatment plans that are aimed
specifically at
increasing the length of those telomeres
or maintaining their length and lastly
uh food allergy testing is something we
do where what we're looking for is foods
that cause low levels of inflammation
you know most people uh know of the the
major allergies uh where you eat peanuts
or shellfish and you know uh turn into
wolf smith from that movie hitch right
where everything puffs up and so those
are
anaphylactic reactions and there are
also lower level reactions where what's
happening is the foods you eat cause
histamine release and that chronic low
level is causing
chronic inflammation throughout the the
body and people just don't feel well and
by testing for
all the different types of foods
additives preservatives
antibiotics molds there's a whole
spectrum that can be tested over 350
different items and then we can start
eliminating those things from the diet
we welcome you to come in you can call
our office and make an appointment for a
consultation and that would be to sit
with me and discuss what's going on the
goal being to to figure out what what
the pinpoint areas are and then getting
the health
and wellness optimization plan rolling
out
thank you regenerate medical concierge
for sponsoring this segment you can find
them in henderson more info just call
702-998-8009 or visit
regeneratemedicalconcierge.com las vegas